RYAN: Today we're talking about
clean energy, manufacturer
spotlight, and innovation
through inclusion.
I'm Ryan, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Having achieved 100%
annual renewable energy
matching every year
since 2017, we're
now focused on achieving
our moonshot goal of 24/7
carbon-free energy by 2030
by purchasing clean energy
generated from an increasingly
diverse set of technologies
to decarbonize grids
across the globe.
We are pleased to share
that clean energy projects
that we signed over
the past few years
across Belgium, Denmark
Chile, and Finland are now
operational, providing
important clean-energy resources
to the grids where we operate,
and taking us one step closer
to 24/7 carbon-free energy.
Head to the blog to learn more.
Join us on May 5 to hear leading
manufacturers and technology
partners discuss how they
transformed operations
and empowered their teams to
solve productivity challenges
and build competitive and
sustainable businesses
with Google Cloud.
You will hear from
thought leaders
how a data platform, data
analytics, and AI models
can create a solid
foundation for scaling
smart-factory initiatives and
enable unique optimization
models.
Jim Hogan is both the
principal innovation strategist
at Google Cloud and the VP of
accessibility and technology
for Google's
Disability Alliance.
Being autistic, he's
faced severe challenges
in finding belonging
in the workplace.
This experience
fires his passion
for workplace equity
on many fronts.
It also informs
his technical work
of aligning corporate
aspirations to the realities
of software architecture.
The common thread, he says,
is delivering outcomes
to customers based
on the understanding
that belonging is the
fuel of innovation.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.